at the start of the movie a woman named
carol heads out to the streets for a
walk but notices something very unusual
people seem to have become soulless as
there is not a fragment of emotion on
anyone's face the place is turned into a
dead town to make matters worse those
showing emotions are apprehended by the
police an elderly woman keeps saying
don't sleep
but even she is captured by the police
after walking for a while a normal
looking cop approaches carol and notices
that she is sweating hence he warns her
to run away or else she will be caught
and killed it appears as if showing
emotions or sleeping will cause death
following this the movie cuts to a few
days ago a space shuttle explodes on
earth's surface and scatters across many
states in the us every media outlet in
the country is covering the news as they
believe that it is the sign of an alien
invasion on the other hand the people
are terrified and they hesitate to touch
the debris fearing that it has been
infected meanwhile the head of the
center of disease control tucker kaufman
arrives at one of the crash sites for
inspection he approaches the research
team and gets to know that the piece of
debris was laced with a mysterious
organism that has the ability to
withstand enormous levels of radiation
the organism can also multiply at a
rapid rate implying that it is from
another planet later while tucker is
preparing to leave he unknowingly
touches a small piece of the debris and
receives a cut on his finger however he
doesn't think much of it which given
that he's the head of the cdc is
ridiculous and proceeds towards his home
that night tucker starts sweating
profusely and experiences an intense
cellular condensation on his face as if
something has taken over him in the next
scene we are introduced to tucker's
ex-wife carol she is a psychiatrist by
profession who lives with their only son
oliver that night oliver has a nightmare
and starts screaming but his mother
immediately springs into action and
calms him down the following morning
carol gets a call from tucker who
expresses his desire to see his son but
as expected she simply says no and hangs
up the call shortly after she drops
oliver off at school and proceeds to her
workplace on the way she runs into her
best friend dr ben driscoll and takes a
lift driscoll mentions that the
government is hiding something serious
from them as all the researchers on the
crash site have resigned however carol
is in no mood to chat about this topic
and instead complains about her
ex-husband she tells driscoll that
tucker has been acting very strange as
of late and he suddenly wants to see
their son despite being away for the
past four years as the two friends
continue their conversation they arrive
outside carol's office and part ways
later carol starts her counseling
session for the day her first patient is
a middle-aged woman named wendy who
reveals that her husband has been acting
very weird as of late just a few days
ago he killed their family dog without
any remorse carol instantly realizes
that something is wrong but for the time
being she just prescribes a few
medications to her patient have some
xanax that'll stop your husband from
killing things after finishing work
carol and her neighbor pam take their
children out trick-or-treating as it is
halloween night when they approach a
house the family dog starts barking
profusely as if it is sensed something
wendy's husband must be nearby carol and
her gang proceed to leave but just then
the dog lunges towards pam's son andy
and tackles him to the ground
surprisingly despite the terrifying
situation the little boy doesn't even
flinch instead he squeezes the dog's
mouth with his bare hands until help
arrives and separates the two shortly
after the group reaches carol's home
where the mothers have a brief chat pam
reveals that andy has been acting very
strange for some days and sometimes she
thinks that he has lost his emotions
however carol being a psychiatrist
assures her that it is very normal for
kids his age suddenly oliver starts
screaming from another room and when
carol reaches there she finds a strange
piece of flesh coming out of his hand
worried she immediately takes it to
driscoll's lab where his friend and
popular scientist dr gagliano starts his
experiments in the meantime a mysterious
virus has started to decimate the
country thousands of people are dying
every day but no one knows the cause of
it as a result an emergency meeting is
held in the capital where all the
prominent researchers are present tucker
kaufman who has been tasked with
headlining the meeting explains that the
new virus is spreading at an
unprecedented rate and if they don't do
anything about it the country will go
into a recession when some researchers
ask about the solution tucker says that
the only way to stem the spread is by
conducting an inoculation program as the
meeting goes on several infected waiters
inside the kitchen are seen puking into
the tea that is going to be served to
everyone ew later that night carol
reluctantly decides to let tucker spend
the weekend with oliver as he is the
father after all while she is driving to
his house a terrified lady suddenly
appears asking for help she keeps
mentioning that something terrible is
about to happen but before she can
reveal the cause a car runs her over
shortly after the cops arrive at the
scene carol asserts that she's ready to
testify against the reckless driver but
the head cop simply tells her to go home
hearing this carol starts assuming that
something really bad is happening in the
city after a while she drops oliver at
tucker's place and leaves that same
night carol and driscoll attend a lavish
party where they engage in a short
conversation with czech diplomat dr
belichick and his wife ludmia the two
then meet other diplomats including dr
yurish and talk about the dark side of
human nature after the party driscoll
tries to kiss carol in the car but the
latter backs off saying that she doesn't
want to ruin their friendship she also
doesn't want that alien sociopath
disease the next morning while carol is
heading to work she notices something
very strange several people have
completely frozen as if their soul has
been taken away when she reaches the
office she is taken aback to find that
all of her clients have cancelled their
appointments for the day just then she
receives a call from driscoll informing
her that the test results of the strange
skin patch have come out in the next
scene carol reaches the lab where dr
gagliano is waiting for her he reveals
that the skin sample is made up of
several molecular spores that take over
the human brain during sleep and alter
the genetic code rendering a person
unstable hence in order to prevent the
deadly infection they are forbidden from
sleeping until they find a cure
meanwhile ludmia calls driscoll and
informs him that dr yurish has been
acting strangely as a result the three
immediately rushed to the diplomats
house where they come across yrish in a
terrible state carol tries taking a
picture of him but suddenly the
monster-like man wakes up and attacks
her however before any serious damage is
caused driscoll thwarts yurish causing
him to vomit a weird liquid and die
following the incident carol becomes
scared and rushes to retrieve oliver
from her ex-husband when she reaches the
place she sees tucker in a meeting with
some of his associates carol is worried
about her son but tucker assures her
that oliver is playing at his friend
gene's house despite this she isn't
convinced and starts looking for her son
but just then the men from the meeting
surround her a terrified carol tries to
run but tucker effortlessly tackles her
to the ground and infects her with his
saliva fortunately she somehow manages
to escape the house and get into her car
carol drives recklessly through the
neighborhood resulting in an accident
when she gets out of the car she is
again chased by a group of infected
people but even this time she evades
them and enters a subway station shortly
after carol gets on the train which is
full of passengers with the same vague
expressions just then she receives a
message from oliver who asks her to save
him immediately as tucker has taken him
somewhere this worries carol and when
she breaks down in desperation a
passenger tells her to act emotionless
if she doesn't want to get caught
suddenly a group of infected passengers
enter the compartment and start a brawl
they try to subdue carol but she somehow
manages to exit the train and flee she
then gets back to the road and witnesses
some cops forcing the uninfected
citizens to be inoculated with the virus
meanwhile an uninfected cop notices the
sweat on her face and tells her to run
indicating that the infected ones cannot
sweat by this time the city is turned
into a war zone and several people are
committing the unthinkable to save
themselves from the virus in the next
scene carol rushes over to the belichick
mansion where driscoll and dr gagliano
are still conducting their tests after a
bit of discussion driscoll decides to
help carol find her son while dr
gagliano and his assistant prepare to
travel to fort dietrich maryland to find
a cure for the virus they also decide to
stay awake fearing that they might have
been infected later when carol and
driscoll head back to the streets they
notice wendy being forcefully taken away
by the cops when she tries resisting the
infected cops zap her with a stick and
knock her out despite this she doesn't
turn carol and driscoll noticed this and
deduced that wendy has somehow developed
an immunity to the virus after a while
the duo steals a police car and arrives
at carroll's office where they begin
searching through wendy's medical
profile driscoll finds out that wendy
was suffering from a brain illness
called encephalitis and this is the
reason why the virus doesn't want to
enter her brain the virus only tends to
attack healthy brains so that it can
feast on it and multiply its number just
then carol gets another text from oliver
mentioning that he is being held at his
grandmother's home in baltimore scared
carol comes clean with driscoll that she
has already been infected with the virus
despite this her best friend assures her
that everything will be all right
following this driscoll somehow manages
to drop carol off at the train station
before the city gets sealed after
sharing an emotional goodbye the two
depart then carol boards the train to
baltimore where she unexpectedly runs
into oliver's friend gene who has also
been infected it turns out that he is
also heading to meet oliver after the
train reaches baltimore tucker arrives
at the station to escort carol and jean
to his mother's place that evening
tucker gets a call from his associates
and heads outside taking this as the
perfect opportunity carol scans through
the house and finally finds her son the
two then have an emotional reunion and
oliver mentions that he is still
uninfected despite sleeping every day
here we get to know that the little boy
is taking constant medication for his
sleeping disorder and that is why he
isn't infected with the virus suddenly
gene approaches the two and tries to
infect them with the virus but carol
easily swats him away and rushes out
with her son on the way out tucker
catches wind of the escape and
immediately chases after his family he
tracks them inside an abandoned
warehouse and tries hurting them but
carol grabs an iron rod and strikes him
in the head finally killing him
following this the mother-son duo enters
a pharmacy where carol finds an
injection and hands it over to her son
she then instructs the boy to inject it
into her in case she falls asleep
meanwhile she gets a call from driscoll
and informs him about their location as
she is busy on the call oliver slowly
approaches a door which has blood
splattered nearby it she immediately
stops him and instead enters herself to
inspect there she notices several
infected people lying on the ground and
rushes out but not before grabbing a gun
from one of them a while later when
little oliver falls asleep carol
desperately searches for medication and
literally anything she can get her hands
on to keep her awake the next morning
the infected people inside the room have
come back to life and they repeatedly
knock on the door to get out this wakes
oliver up and when he realizes that his
mother has fallen asleep he swiftly
injects her with the syringe saving her
life but the danger is far from averted
the infected people inside the room
continue banging on the door ferociously
just when it seems that all hope is lost
driscoll arrives at the location carol
is ecstatic to see him but when she
finds out that he too has become
infected she backs away from him
driscoll keeps mentioning that the virus
has made him more powerful and he now
feels invigorated he also tries
persuading carol to join him mentioning
that the new society will have no
problems such as crime hatred
discrimination and so on a terrified
carol points her gun at him but driscoll
still opens the door and lets out all
the other infected people then he
mentions that the infected people hate
the immune ones pointing at oliver
saying this everyone tries to apprehend
the little boy but carol shoots and
kills them one by one when it's
driscoll's turn she simply shoots him in
the leg and escapes with oliver outside
they steal a police car and narrowly
avoids several infected people while
driving around haphazardly carol gets a
call from dr goliano who tells her to
come to a building where a chopper is
ready to take off following the
instructions carol somehow reaches the
place with oliver and finally they are
saved in the final scene we are shown
that scientists have finally created a
vaccine for the deadly virus because of
this the virus has been eradicated from
the entire world and life has become
normal again dr gagliano who is one of
the driving forces behind the vaccine
reveals in an interview that the
vaccinated people will have no memories
of the earlier events meanwhile carol
has adopted jean and she is now in a
relationship with driscoll the movie
ends as oliver and jean head to school
while driscoll reads a newspaper
completely unaware of the heroism that
he showed a year earlier subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching